[Music]
the end of the world is not something we
like to think about
especially as there are plenty of
apocalypses to choose from
in 1552 an anonymous author captured his
doomsday fears onto parchment
known as the book of miracles it is
perhaps the world's most disturbing
picture book with scenes of calamity and
chaos and eerie hybrids that define
logic
all were believed to be omens that the
apocalypse was on its way
these mesmerizing images invoke a sense
of dread the kind of dread that arises
from things we don't understand with
haunting creatures that inhabit our
nightmares welcome to strange christian
art this episode
the little book of cosmic horrors
[Music]
the name of this book is the book of
miracles now this implies something
pleasant or wonderful but this book is
far from that instead it's full of
disturbing visions like the week in 1542
when the sky caught fire or in 1550 when
a pool of human blood bubbled from the
ground the sort of things that don't
happen on the daily
each one of these strange illustrations
includes the year in which it happened
and a very brief description
there is no attempt however at an
explanation
but what is the purpose of this book why
draw such disturbing images
it's believed that this book was a
warning illustrating omens believed to
have been sent by god
omens that suggested that the apocalypse
was nigh it might explain why so many of
these pictures are comments for
millennia comets have been seen as signs
of bad luck
like in the bao tapestry which records
the transit of halley's comet in 1066
the same year that the kingdom of
england was conquered by the normans
if you look closely at these
illustrations you can see silhouettes of
collapsing cities in the background
the origin of this book is just as
intriguing as its contents
in 2007 it anonymously surfaced in an
auction house in augsburg germany no one
knows who wrote it or the journey it had
been on up to this point
to me it adds to the mystery as well as
its supernatural quality the book has
been dated to 1552 as after this year
there are no further entries it was
written during a time of conflict and
upheaval as western christianity split
between catholics and protestants a
period known as the reformation
at the time anxieties about the end of
the world reached an all-time high the
book was probably commissioned in
response to those fears to keep track of
god's signs throughout history the types
of signs that typically precede an
apocalypse let's take a look inside
shall we
the first few pages depict scenes from
the bible taken from the old testament
it includes familiar stories like noah's
ark when god drowned the earth with a
great flood or the destruction of sodom
and gomorrah when god engulfed a town in
a fiery inferno there are other less
destructive scenes too even one
including the old testament's weirdest
chapter the vision of ezekiel perhaps
familiar to viewers of the channel it's
a fantastical glimpse of god's throne
accompanying him are two creatures to
the left a winged hybrid with the heads
of a human an eagle an ox and a line
to the right an interlocking set of
rings with eyes on the outer rim
in hebrew it's referred to as an ophanim
or the wheels
it's odd to see something so unnatural
yet so apparently holy perhaps it's the
multiple heads and eyes that make them
so unnerving these mysterious angels are
bizarre inhabiting a plane beyond human
comprehension
after exploring scenes from the bible
the book records signs that have taken
place throughout history right up to the
modern day which in this case was the
year 1552 many of these are a classic
doomsday omens volcanic eruptions locust
plagues comets they're your go-to's in
apocalypse bingo but then the book
starts to get really really strange with
illustrations of some highly unusual
incidents like the orb of 73 bc when a
golden sphere suddenly appeared above
ancient rome according to the
description it came down to earth rolled
about and flew back up into the air
again blocking out the sun
entirely there's no explanation as to
what it could be just a very
matter-of-fact description
but i think i have an idea you see this
orb story seems to be based on an actual
report from ancient rome in 76 bc roman
naturalist pliny the elder described a
very similar event how a bright spark
flew down to earth hovered about a bit
and disappeared entirely
what he had just described was a rare
meteorological phenomenon known as a
bolide these when meteorites burn
exceptionally bright in the atmosphere
giving the appearance of a glowing orb
whilst they're incredibly rare some have
been caught on camera just look at this
video taken from russian dash cam in
2013
where would humanity be without russian
dash cam footage the great library of
weird goings-on
going back to our image the orb of 73 bc
was probably a bolide a burning hot
meteorite which glows like an orb in the
sky just like the one pliny the elder
seems to have described although by the
time of this illustration the original
story had undergone a fair bit of
creative embellishment
many images featured disturbances with
the sun in 1551 the sun allegedly
multiplied into five of the town of
leipzig this picture features the sun
with a bright glowing ring followed by
the devastation you'd come to expect
some illustrations have these eerie
halos and ghostly rings that illuminate
the sky
strangely there are accounts of this
very same thing outside our book like
this painting from 1535 with rings over
stockholm sweden the celestial halos
have a name sun dogs and are a real
atmospheric phenomenon they occur when
atmospheric ice crystals refract the
sunlight creating an eerie halo illusion
in the sky throughout history sun dogs
have often been mistaken for divine
activity who could blame them we know
far more about atmospheric signs than we
did back then now of course most of
these events don't have a rational
explanation like how a red warrior
appeared in the sky along with a
floating crimson fortress and a shadowy
army or in 1533 when a ghostly horse
appeared over bohemia with a nebulous
rider climbing on
that was a particularly odd year for the
people of bohemia
late that year the sky was also swarming
with dragons wearing crowns a highlight
for me has to be the cosmic baby battle
of 1536 when three celestial infants
appeared to be doing battle in the sky
one is wearing the austrian coat of arms
the other two are dressed up like
ottomans possibly a reference to the
failed turkish siege of vienna in 1529
with all these ultra strange events it's
doubtful whether they actually happened
however at the same time there's no way
to prove that they didn't happen
i can dream
[Music]
so far we've seen all the strange
happenings in the sky but what about on
the ground
another core focus of the book is the
various monsters
from the giant whale that caused an
earthquake in lisbon to this hydra-like
creature that was caught by fishermen
and taken to venice some of these beasts
are very hard to spot this scene looks
pretty normal until you notice this
hairy creature with a human face
i have no clue what this is but it does
look like early drawings of sloths now
this creature was reportedly dredged out
of the tiber river in rome it is the
head of a donkey the body of a human and
two faces on its backside when i first
saw this image i immediately recognized
the sketch it was based on the same
creature appears in this protestant
cartoon by lucas cranach the elder it's
a caricature of the pope who's dressed
as a demonic donkey even the background
is the same it appears that our
illustrator might have misunderstood the
image's original purpose
instead of protestant propaganda he
added a whole backstory about an actual
monster that washed up in rome unless
that is he was secretly joining in the
satire there are other hybrid creatures
just like this one malformed and
misshapen beings both animal and human
since ancient times hybrids have been
seen as evil abominations that go
against the laws of nature this
revulsion towards hybridity continues
today when we see a creature that
shouldn't exist we tend to label it as
creepy or unsettling
whilst hybrids have often been seen as
evil they were at the same time holy
remember those angels at the start of
the book those multi-bodied multi-eyed
creatures
well they're associated with the divine
and are therefore good
presumably
our book contains these opposite
approaches to hybrids on one hand
they're hellish but on the other they're
divine it's an uncomfortable balance but
one that's interesting to see play out
before our eyes
the book ends where it started
the bible it now focuses on the
apocalyptic visions from the book of
revelation if you've watched my survival
guide to the biblical apocalypse you'll
know all the gruesome devastation that's
supposed to take place
trumpets hailing destruction an
explosion of man man-eating locusts
dragons during corpses all the good
stuff
the last image depicts the arrival of
the beast a multi-headed monster with
ten crowns beside him is the antichrist
who looks like a mix between a goat and
a dog
worshiping the arrival of these
creatures are men dressed in catholic
garb among them are bishops cardinals
and even the pope this detail confirms
that whoever wrote this was most likely
a protestant who had a bone to pick with
the catholic church
with this foreboding image the book
draws to a close
the book of miracles is an incredibly
strange piece of christian art a
collection of bizarre signs each with a
unique flavor of doom and destruction
whilst you can identify what some of
these signs actually were others defy
explanation
looking through the pages of this book
there's one word which comes to mind
fear
fear of the unexplained fear of monsters
fear of divine judgment you can feel
this fear in every picture as our author
draws the omens of a vengeful god who
one day will bring his creation to a
violent end
and there's nothing we humans can do to
stop it
in this way it reminds me of a genre
called cosmic horror
you'll be familiar with its most famous
writer h.p lovecraft whose gothic
stories of dark magic and profane
deities explore the fragile limits of
human knowledge
many of lovecraft's stories include
catholic gods like cthulhu an
octopus-like deity that lurks at the
bottom of the sea
you'll notice he relies on that same
fear of hybrid monsters
whilst lovecraft's stories and the book
of miracles come from different time
periods and weren't connected in any way
both explore that idea of otherness
things that don't make sense things we
can't explain
that fear of the unknown drives much of
what we see in the book of miracles
i guess it's fortunate that none of
these grim visions have come to pass
let's hope they never will
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i had a great
time making this and i hope you enjoyed
it as well
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye